hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome classical game between these two
old rivals it's uh sergey karyakin vs
magnus carlson and this is round five of
the 2021 norway chess uh let's dive
straight into it as there is quite a lot
to cover so we're to have a line that
you guys know all too well it's a line
that has been played many times in the
world chess championship match between
carlson and fabiano caruana in 2018 in
london uh but we're going to talk a bit
more about that when we show some moves
so e4 we have c5 by magnus going for his
sicilian defense knight to f3 knight to
c6 and now d4 striking in the center we
have captures captures and now knight to
f6 we have knight to c3 and now going
for e5 the famous uh svechnikov
variation sometimes called the pelican
sometimes called alaska variation but in
modern times uh or mostly mostly the
slashnikov uh knight d to b5 now with
ideas of maybe getting the knight to d6
would check the knight and the queen
covered that square very nicely so d6
now the bishop also protects that pawn
uh and knights the d5 now so going for
that knight to c7 check uh black of
course will capture on the five knight
characters e captures and now knight to
e7 if you remember in the world chase
championship match between magnus and
fabi both knights the b8 and knight to
the e7 were played quite a few times so
knight to the e7 and c4 adding more more
defense to this d5 pawn but also keeping
an eye on the knight so you don't run
into maybe some trickery with queen a5
check
we have knights the g6 now and the queen
to a4 now threatening some nasty
discoveries the king is still on e8 we
have bishop to d7 and now queen to b4
attacking this pawn twice so queen to b8
defending and now h4 preparing to
dislodge the knight with h5 so magnus
blocks it we have h5 and now bishop to
e3 just continuing development we have
a6 chasing away the knight knight to c3
and now we reach the position that was
uh
in the world chess championship match it
was uh in game 14 of the match that this
position was reached so after 12
classical games it was reached in the
second rapid game uh where uh magnus
played uh a5 here attacked fabi's queen
but here we have bishop to e7 by magnus
so he deviates from his own game uh with
fabi uh we have g3 and now there are
some games where a5 now was played also
uh here f5 is a known move but here
magnus castles and it is now as of move
15 that we have a completely new game
and i've caught a glimpse of the
interview after the game where they
asked
karjakin uh
what to what point was he familiar with
the position he i think he said uh well
right about when magnus castle that he
was not familiar with the castles so as
you can see it is a completely new move
so bishop to e2 this bishop belongs here
very nicely because i've seen some
carlson games in this line where he
sometimes even sacrifices this pawn to
get the e5 square for his knight and
then the knight will be very strong here
with having access to d3 and f3 squares
so the bishop here is doing a fine job
keeping an eye on those um squares but
also just going after that h5 pawn so b5
magnus ignores this pawn i think he
already had a few games where he
sacrifices it with c captures on b five
eight captures and now karjakin just
grabs it we have bishop captures on h5
uh bishop to d8 now shifting the bishop
over to a5 to put the bishop on this
strong diagonal and now um you have to
decide you want to capture on g6 and
allow magnus the open f file maybe uh
for example after this we could see
castles then bishop to a5 it's it's a
really crazy position where uh karjakin
obviously knows that magnus has this
very well prepared
so instead after bishop to d8 he just
castles the safety he already grabbed
the h5 pawn and no reason to to you know
push for it too much uh knight to e7 uh
end now comes bishop to g5
uh we have bishop to a5 now going after
that queen you could also maybe consider
f6 here but
not the magnus's liking so bishop to a5
chasing away the queen queen b3 and now
knight to f5 so now you have to be
somewhat careful if for example bishop
comes to b6 you always have to watch out
for knight captures and g3 so knights
the e2 the knight now also will help out
with the defense of the g3 pawn and the
bishop to b6 so now this knight can't
really move because you get this knight
captures on g3 idea so rook ate the c1
getting the rook the only open file on
the board and now magnus plays rook to
a4 gaining very nice control of the
entire fourth rank here uh and now you
could continue this um
game a lot of ways but the move that
karjakin plays is definitely the the
more enjoyable one he plays rook to c6
and we've reached a position from the
thumbnail where he's offering magnus the
exchange uh but uh he will have a very
very dangerous pass pawn here now you
could decline this there are many ways
of declining this for example queen to
a7 being one of them saying that you can
never really capture on b5 if you
capture here i'm going to play rook to
b8 and now i have all the compensation i
need i have bishop and queen on this
beautiful diagonal the rook attacking a2
district attacking b2 so you haven't
really won a pawn it's just uh you know
a better position for me but magnus says
nope i accept your challenge and he
plays bishop captures on c6 and this is
this is where our game truly begins we
have d captures on c6 now with this
beautiful past pawn here and rook the c
for now uh not allowing this uh constant
pressure along this diagonal
so what could you play now if you if you
go for something like queen captures on
b5 of course you blunder the queen just
bishop captures and f2 and we're not
having that so here we have a4 giving up
uh
giving up upon uh trying to get magnus
to go rook captures on a4 and real
captures on a4 is something magnus
doesn't want to do
but it is the strongest line i will show
it because it's very enjoyable so here
if you if you accept the pawn then white
gets to play bishop to g6 as the f pawn
is pinned now the knight is attacked and
once you move it let's say knight to d4
we're gonna capture it and after bishop
captures we're gonna play bishop to e7
attacking the rook here you can't move
the rook because well then the f7 pawn
just falls and once you play something
like rook to c4 it is uh actually
perfectly fine for black you don't
really care you're already up the
exchange so you might just uh
give it back and enjoy you know a better
position now white doesn't really have
anything but
anything good to continue here
and if you capture the rook then you've
really given up all you've worked for
for example f captures on g6 you don't
even have to worry about opening up this
position if bishop p7 we're just going
to play king h7 on pin now the rook can
move and let's say after the bishop
moves we're going to play queen to b6
and the black has a very very enjoyable
game you keep an eye on the past c6 pawn
and you have two connected pass pawns of
your own it's definitely black who's
better here so this a4 move definitely
confused magnus and the magnus played
the knight to d for now uh but this only
helps sergey so knight captures on d4
bishop captures on d4 and now a captures
on b5 and now karjakin has uh well uh
two even stronger connected past pawns
than magnus uh we have d5 now defending
the rook here and now rook to c1
uh so once he wants to get uh another
pair of rocks traded off the board rook
captures we have bishop captures and now
queen to b6 regarding these two uh uh
past pawns from advancing further and
now hopefully you can get this bishop uh
somewhere and then start pushing your
own pawns or rather a pawn this is still
not a pass pawn the df pawn is still
here uh and what do you do
well uh this pawn is attacked so you
have to defend it so bishop to e3 you
might try some other moves but bishop to
e3 is definitely the best
and you don't you don't really have a
good way of dealing with this if you
don't capture uh
sergey will just capture on d5 so magnus
goes for this capture we have f captures
on e3 and now this is the position that
magnus got he's up the exchange uh but
he has to worry about these two
connected past pawns uh and the
situation on the clock is uh sergey 18
minutes
magnus 30 minutes on the clock so what
do you play here here magnus played the
immediate rook to d3 uh
you could try pushing d4 right away and
maybe this is even more precise but it's
uh it's an extremely complicated
position so it's very hard to say for
example captures captures this comes
with check and now you would have the
highly exposed white king maybe you
could you know do do some damage this
way so it would the white would have to
be incredibly precise to get something
here because
if you also allow the rook to enter the
attack then it could all be over very
soon but magnus decided to prepare the
push he played the rook to d8 first and
now we have king to g2 absolutely
strongest getting the king off of this
diagonal so now you can continue the
game we have g6 pushing this bishop back
bishop to e2 and now king to g7 uh
magnus also wants to get his king off of
this diagonal we have queen to c3 and
now magnus pushes uh d4 we have e
captures e captures and now queen to d3
now uh you have this very nice position
where your structure here is very safe
um you have uh blocked the blacks only
pass pawn and you you you can you you
have a lot to be happy for and now how
do you continue magnus plays queen to a5
he wants to somehow get the the queen
into the game and now queen to c2 uh
instead of queen to c2 you should just
play h5 kinda goes into the whole uh
principle of two weaknesses thing as the
the past pawn on the queen's queen side
are one weakness and now if you expose
the black king uh to checks that would
be the second weakness and then you you
you would be able to use that to your
advantage for example if queen b4 we're
gonna play captures captures now queen
e4 and now this king is widely exposed
you can you know have to worry about c7
all the time and the white would have a
very easy win here but he first played
queen to c2 and now comes queen to b4
now putting pressure now on this spawn
uh but also maybe after queen to c2 rook
to e8 putting pressure on this bishop
here uh might give black a very valuable
tempo but okay both players were already
very low on the clock here and it's
moved 38 we have to reach time control
so two more moves so after queen to b4
we have b3 limit limiting the mobility
of carlson's queen and only now rook to
e8 so putting pressure on the bishop
here and now uh we have bishop to for as
uh you can't move the queen the bishop
would be hanging but here white does
have a forced win i'm going to show it
because it's very enjoyable just c7 now
the problem with c7 is that it kind of
looks like it doesn't work because you
can always just attack the pawn and now
how are you going to deal with uh
uh
the queen again attacking this pawn for
example queen d6 you're not going to be
able to defend this pawn but it wins by
force bishop g4 there's that and now
after f5 just bishop captures on f5 it's
silly but it works g captures queen
captures now the rook either moves and
then you bring another queen into the
game or you capture in the simple rook a
queen to e5 check picks up the rook king
will move king g6 we're gonna capture
the rook and we have four pawns to one
and even if black captures one of them
it's it's not enough
we still have more than enough to win
this game uh but okay bishop to c4
safety first uh says karjakin uh and now
comes rook to e7 by magnus so trying to
keep an eye on that seventh rank but
maybe playing actively here would rook
to e3 uh would do a lot of good to black
because uh it's uh very unclear and very
uh difficult to continue the game for
for white if you just push c7 just queen
d6 and black wins the game there's
really nothing you can do you will
either get checkmated or you lose the
pass pawn which is pretty much your only
trump card so instead after bishop to c4
magnus played rook the e7 kind of a
passive the passive defending move now
comes queen to f2 putting pressure on on
f7 and also going for for this pawn here
so queen to c3 defending now queen to f3
offering a queen trait and magnus just
goes back here maybe worth considering
was f5 and well you don't really care
about this queen trade here but the the
main thing is if queen d5 going after
some trickery here you can play king h6
and black is again very safe here but
these are crazy lines and uh well not
not easy to find and again they they do
get increment now but they're still very
low on time so after queen f3 we have
queen to be for by magnus and now comes
king to h3 uh again uh the the correct
here is queen to d5 because it really uh
limits
black from doing anything there's no
good move here that black and play
everything is just completely tied up
and if you try some checks for example
queen d2 check king here and now let's
say queen f2 trying to get some checks
in just c7 and it's enough to win the
game you still can't capture it just
queen e5 check picks up the rook and
there's well there's no good move here
uh and of course if queen to f1 check
then we just capture the queen if any of
you guys miss that so after queen to b4
we have king to h3 uh better than to
calculate all of this maybe we just you
know don't allow queen to d to check and
then we push c7 so here queen to d6 now
magnus guards the c7 square and now
queen f4 he offers a queen trade and
magnus has to figure out what to do uh
if you if you don't capture the queen
you you haven't really made any progress
but if you capture the queen it's still
not better but magnus decides to capture
it and now we have g captures on f3 and
now magnus plays d3 and this was his uh
uh move that uh maybe maybe could bring
him some happiness in this game but it
is not enough so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move for karjakin here while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting it as you
know it's it's not all that simple of a
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's bishop captures
on d3 that's right we give up the bishop
to stop the past pawn and then our
connected pass pawns will do do the job
right so rook the e3 with check king to
g2 with rook captures on d3 and now b6
so these pawns are now unstoppable as
you you know uh rook captures on b3 now
b7 and now the threat is c7 and then if
rook captures of course we just bring
the queen into the game so here magnus
tries rook to b6 but it's not enough of
course c7 wins the game on the spot but
sergey first wants to create some
further weaknesses on the king side uh
just to prevent magnus from maybe
creating some sort of a castle like a
some sort of a fortress
so h5
postponing c7 we have g captures on h5
and now king to h3 uh we have rook
captures on c6 there's really nothing
better to do here you
either otherwise c7 will be played so b8
bringing a queen into the game now comes
rook to c5 we have queen to b2 with
check f6 and now king to h4 and he was
in this position on move 54 that magnus
carlsen resigned in the game and what an
impressive victory for sergey karjakin
uh in this uh well classical game uh in
a line that magnus knows probably better
than everyone in the entire world as he
prepared it for the world chess
championship match he had against fabi
uh but as you can see anyone can get
surprised and here there were quite a
few surprises uh it was a completely
crazy game white could have gone better
many times black could have gone better
many times and you know in this
craziness uh this time sergey was
victorious
uh so yeah uh if this spawn wasn't here
black would actually have a
well a very good fortress you could just
play rook t five rook to g5 rookie five
rogue g5 and not much for white to do
there the the white king couldn't get
across uh but the the existence of the
f4 pawn makes that impossible and of
course uh magnus knows this
so yeah here he resigned and uh we're
gonna check out one more game at least
from this uh from this round five and
then we're finally gonna check out the
standings uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
john queenie matthew coleman david
chester tom derelow and the beef aisle
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing with
another game from this round uh
and that's it thank you all i will see
you soon and hope you had an excellent
sunday